we have a full range  of domains on which they can be a  support combining  what eda can do and what the european  commission  can do to support those dual use  capabilities  so  is  patreon  fun  so  so  is  my mission on board is  to handle the guns i'm a rescue man  and other stuff some more that can be  important like  steer the boat and keep the area clear  come on  my origin is actually not so far away  from here i am  my parents are from eritrea and  now contributing out here in the gulf of  eden as a norwegian  is very special for me and this is a  very meaningful  mission protecting seafarers and world  food program is  yeah we couldn't have done anything else  than what we're doing right now  i'm working in the opel cops mission  in palestine and my job  is to mentor advice and support  the pcp police gender advisor in the  palestinian civilian police  you